سابدا معك المعتز بالله حسن من ميناء
الاسكندرون ما اخر اوضاع الحريق وتداعياته
طبعا نحن غادرنا نحن غادرنا قبل قليل
ميناء اسكندرون ودخلنا الى داخله المدينه
في كان الوضع ال سي هو الدوام اشتعال
الحرائق هناك والجهود لاطفاء هذه الحرائق
هنا في المدينه اردت ان اريكم الصوره ايضا
في المدينه ما زالت عمليات ازاله الانقاذ
مستمره في المدينه
ومحاوله الوصول الى ناجين هذه المدينه
التاريخيه التي ارتبطت بهذا الميناء
الشهير والقديم هي حالها هكذا هناك في
الجهه المقابله كما تشاهدون ما زالت اليات
تعمل لمحاوله اخراج من علقوا تحت الالقاد
قبل قليل فقط كان هناك ناجل من هنا طلب
الناس بان تاتي سيارات الاسعاف للامبولانس
كما يقولون هنا واخرجوا احد الاشخاص الذي
كان موجودا من هنا وسط تصفيق وتهليل
وتكبير بخروج هذا الشخص نحن نتحدث اليوم
السادس للزلزال
ويقول الاتراك انها معجزه ان يخرج احد في
هذا الوقت وبالتالي ما زالت جهود الانقاذ
مستمره هنا في مدينه اسكندرون من اجل
محاوله اخراج مزيد من الاشخاص في تحت هذه
الانقاض ولكن الوضع في هذه المدينه هو وضع
كما تشاهدين هناك دمار نتيجه هذا هذا
الزلزال وهناك
محاولات عده للوصول الى الناجين والامل
دائما موجود كما يقول الاتراك هنا ماذا عن
الذين فقدوا منازلهم هل هناك جهود للايواء
في تلك المدينه وماذا ايضا عن اوضاع
الخدمات الاخرى الموجوده مستشفيات
اغذيه ادويه
الوضع في مدينه اسكندرون هو ذاته في مدينه
حطاي والمدن الاخرى من اديمان الى ديار
بكر الى
ربما اضن كل هذه المدن يتاثرت بالزلزال
وبالتالي هناك سعي لمساعده الاشخاص الذين
يمكن ان يتم اياهم داخل خيم ولكن مع ذلك
هذه الخيم قد لا تكفي هناك اناس كثيرون هم
بحاجه لاواء ولكن
هناك متطوعون يحاولون ايضا المساعده في
هذا الموضوع موضوع الخدمات ايضا هو موضوع
مهم لان المدينه في
معظمها ايضا تضررت هناك ربما حاجه لان
يكون هناك صيدليات وكل ذلك
يسعى القائمون ربما على محاوله
تامينه ولكن الوضع بشكل عام هو وضع صعب
لان الدمار بالزلزال هو دمار واسع جدا
وليس هنا فقط 10 محافظات في تركيا